what happened on election night was that
multiple crucial counties in the country
just stopped counting
why i don't know i don't know
we're getting reports in it that in
certain places and this wouldn't be
enough to swing the election but it
would be enough to
change the vote count if it happened in
multiple places votes are being reported
off by an order of magnitude when people
are reporting them so they've been fixed
in some places
how many places have they not been fixed
we know in georgia there's illegal
ballots going on
a republican poll observer in georgia
saw 53
late absentee ballots illegally added to
a stack of on-time absentee ballots in
chatham county
and the republican official says that we
will not allow democrat officials to
steal this election from trump
with late illegal ballots it depends on
the state but in certain states like
georgia if the ballot comes in
late it cannot count now what the
democrats will say is we want every vote
to count that's the joe biden campaign
we need every vote to count and they
make something of an argument right
it's a heartstrings argument to say
every vote in america every voice has to
count
but there are rules to elections if i go
vote right now
well especially if i go vote because i'm
a republican then my vote won't count
but
of course it shouldn't count if you're
voting days after the election your vote
should not count but that was
the the thought process here among
democratic officials i
guarantee i bet the farm on it if you
delay
the count more votes can come in and
that's what
republican poll watchers are seeing
happen in georgia
another irregularity that's going on
you saw this in wisconsin is a major
major voter surge
so voter turnout with 98 of precincts
reporting
shows that nearly 9 out of 10 registered
voters
cast ballots 89 percent of wisconsin
voters cast ballots
now wisconsin does have same-day
registration but we don't have the same
day registration numbers
so we don't know how that number is and
i can just tell you
as a matter of elections 89 percent is
an
implausible voter turnout number that
does not happen
it's usually closer to around 60 percent
maybe
maybe you can tick up higher sometimes
it's even lower than that
now we're trying to pretend it's 89 that
is
statistically impossible now with
same-day voter registration maybe the
numbers i don't know 77 78
that is still implausible very difficult
to believe
think about this president trump got
something like 5 million extra votes
this year than he did in 2016.
that doesn't happen in re-election years
barack obama got millions fewer
votes in 2012 than he did in 2008.
president trump gets something like 5
million more votes and it's still not
enough
very difficult to believe that i suppose
it could be true but it's very difficult
to believe that now speaking of the poll
watchers at every election this is why
we have election day by the way
and why voting before election day is
not legitimate
in in very narrow circumstances if you
can't leave if you have an absentee
ballot
perhaps exceptions prove rules but
election day exists for a reason
because people try to commit fraud and
in michigan the poll watchers
are not even being given access to the
count so the reason that
both campaigns have poll watchers to
make sure people aren't cheating
in in certain parts of michigan the
trump campaign poll watchers can't even
get in
what's going on there very difficult for
me to believe that that's a fair count
if they're not letting them in in other
places in this country you saw election
officials
putting boards up on windows so that the
public could not look in
and see the vote count what's going on
there
i point to these individual
irregularities
because one of them if it were just one
in isolation that would not be enough to
say
there's something illegitimate going on
but when you add them
all up we can only touch on a handful on
this show when you add them all up
you have to start wondering what is
going on here how about skewed election
results in michigan also in michigan
michigan crucial state
that was going heavily for trump then
you know you wait a few days and
i don't know something's changing now
it's more of a democrat state
the antrim county clerk cheryl guy
became aware of skewed results in the
unofficial election result tabulations
so early morning this is yesterday early
morning unofficial result results
showed single-digit returns in the
presidential race
for donald trump in townships including
gestonia echo helena
and torch lake with 65 to 80 reporting
so you're telling me there's gonna be
six or seven votes
in those townships for donald trump i
don't believe that
antrim county is a republican stronghold
it has been for a very long time
but then in certain precincts there joe
biden and other democratic candidates
had many many many more votes than
normal
this is according to a former michigan
state lawmaker quote it just looked
weird
two-thirds of the townships looked
really messed up
now you don't need to take my word for
it this isn't just some
conservative observer a conservative
activist a conservative politician even
this is the
county clerk county clerk's saying
something's really wrong here something
stinks
we know plenty stinks in pennsylvania
something seems to stink in michigan too
but speaking of pennsylvania consider
this this is from 538 by the way this is
nate silver's outfit which i don't
remember i think the last time they
predicted an election correctly
was 2008 with barack obama it's the
whole reason 538 started
but for some reason everyone pays
attention and made silver is this great
genius
nate silver says two more batches of
pennsylvania votes were reported
around 23 277 votes in philadelphia
all for biden all forbidden 23
277 votes and then
5300 votes in lucerne county 4 000 of
which were for biden
so even that number 4 thousand out of
5300 very difficult to believe
but it's extremely difficult for me to
believe that 23 270-70 votes in philly
were all 100
for joe biden i don't know that we can
quite believe that and then
this brings us to north carolina north
carolina as far as i'm concerned the
biggest issue of all
we got results out of florida which is
usually a very contested
pla state right florida was the reason
we had the 38-day recount for bush v
gore
we got results out of ohio another
contested state
that was fine all on election night we
get results we've gotten results now out
of west coast states
states in the middle of the country all
on election night or shortly thereafter
but north carolina polls closed very
early there east coast state
north carolina trump doing very very
well in
we don't have the numbers nbc news is
estimating that about 300 000 votes are
left
to be tallied but north carolina first
of all why couldn't north carolina count
the votes
we don't know but north carolina's
not even counting them anymore north
carolina did not count those
ballots yesterday they just stopped
north carolina says
that they will not give us a number
until november 12th
november 12th what day is it today the
fifth
what's taking so long north carolina
what are you all doing
you might suggest that one of the
reasons that north carolina's
data why their numbers aren't going to
come in until so late
is because if joe biden gets into
trouble it would certainly help joe
biden to win north carolina i don't know
i'm not proposing that
what i do know is ballot box stuffing
is an undeniable american tradition and
specifically an undeniable democratic
party tradition
there is nothing conspiratory well there
is something conspiratorial about that
it's a conspiracy to do it
but it's happened for a long time in
this country
the other thing is that it's not just
one irregularity or two irregularities i
want to make sure that i don't sound
like democrats in 2016 when i'm raising
questions
about some of these numbers democrats in
2016 said this is an illegitimate
election
i said why is that they said because
russia
i said what did russia do they i don't
know they did something
okay we had an investigation into that
by the way russia bought a hundred
thousand dollars worth of facebook ads
some of which were four democrats by the
way
so that claim was ridiculous but here
we've got a lot of questions
shutting down the counting delaying the
counting until november third in north
carolina the
multiple reports of ballot stuffing the
multiple reports of republican poll
watchers
not being allowed to look at the results
the issue of sharpies in arizona that
may
raise questions over whether ballots
could be counted this was in republican
strongholds apparently election
officials passed out
sharpies instead of pens sharpies there
were some questions as to whether or not
they could be counted now arizona saying
they could be counted
who knows who knows all of these issues
and we haven't even scratched the
surface
raised questions about this process to
say nothing of widespread unsolicited
mail and ballots which are
which are truly unprecedented in this
country and rife for fraud the reason we
have poll watchers in the first place
is because there is so much opportunity
for fraud and the left is not going to
admit that
if the numbers just keep miraculously
ticking up
in their favor i hope you enjoyed that
short segment from the michael knowles
show be sure to check out the full
episode
linked in the description or download
the podcast wherever you listen to
[Music]
podcasts
[Music]
you